pues además de lisa murkowski que es
senadora republicana por alaska se suma
el senador patrick tome de pensilvania
quien en medios locales esta mañana dijo
que el donald trump tiene que salir
cuanto antes de la casa blanca a esta
presión también se le suman las voces de
los demócratas que ahora dicen que la
votación para el proceso de impeachment
en la cámara de representantes-
empezaría este martes sin embargo hay
que tener en cuenta que aunque la pruebe
la cámara de representantes que es de
mayoría demócrata el proceso de
impeachment tiene que pasar por el
senado y tiene que ser aprobado por dos
tercios del senado es decir cerca de 17
senadores republicanos tendrían que pues
a pesar apoyar la iniciativa demócrata
de pues es sacar a donald trump a través
del impeachment de la casa blanca le
cuento que varios demócratas sin embargo
han dicho que no quieren que empiece el
proceso el impeachment para no obstruir
los las iniciativas y las metas que
tiene yo bailé en presidente electo
empezando su gobierno entre otras cosas
la confirmó
de la cantidad de leyes y de personas de
su gabinete que quiere que se aprueben y
por último también crece la presión y
pues oficiales de la policía ya se están
abriendo investigaciones para determinar
si hubo conexión complicidad y
negligencia de las fuerzas policiales
con los manifestantes pro trompa para
tomarse el capitolio cristóbal pues es
una situación sumamente tensa y es que
también hay preocupación y sorpresa por
la muerte del oficial livengood que
detalles se conocen al respecto cómo
avanzan las investigaciones tras lo
ocurrido en el capitolio
usted lo decía ya son dos los policías
que mueren tras los ataques al capitolio
la segunda víctima es este oficial de 51
años hold living que pues él estaba a
cargo de la seguridad del congreso de
hecho ya varios senadores en sus cuentas
de twitter republicanos y demócratas le
han agradecido por su labor y pues se
han solidarizado con la familia este
señor estuvo pues tratando de vigilar y
evitar el ingreso de estos manifestantes
al capitolio y pues el oficial ex
oficial de la policía dijo que se
confirma la muerte de este oficial por
suicidio además pues hay varios
senadores que pues están también
apoyando esta nueva investigación de al
menos 25 casos de terrorismo doméstico
que abre la justicia y el departamento
de defensa de eeuu concretamente el
secretario de las fuerzas armadas
brian mccarthy que dice que 25
sospechosos van a ser investigados
precisan
por eso por terrorismo doméstico